what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay too powerful for Marvel movies
onslaught now we had to do onslaught
right like we had to do onslaught oh my
god okay so like you want to talk about
this over power just totally broken
that's onslaught man he was so he do he
was due at his peak man like it was dude
it was insane
okay so here's the deal onslaught was
part and parcel to Marvel kind of
rebooting right a moment of the really
reboot per say they don't really they
just do like kinda like these soft reset
and Marvel like like basically every
title in the 1990s except for like
spider-man and the x-men was doing bad
so Marvel was like let's just reboot
them kind of but not really and so they
created onslaught now like everything
that happens in Marvel Comics with the
x-men it all goes back to fatal
attractions so fatal attractions in the
1990s that's the story that almost all
of you guys know even if you don't know
what the name is it's the story where
Magneto tears the Wolverine out of Adam
or a deters the bullring here's the
Wolverine out of adamantium pose the
adamantium out of Wolverine and it's one
of the coolest moments ever right liked
Magneto's got his acolytes and he's
doing magneto stuff and he's like you
know whatever blog I've got asteroid a
more Avalon wherever the hell he called
it at the time and the x-men are afraid
like these are gonna pop off and magneto
is kind of freaking out you know because
like all man humanity's gonna attack us
and humanity's like we're gonna blow you
guys up with nukes and all I kind of
stuff so the x-men basically traveled to
go see what's going on and then like
somebody somewhere starts some right
like they they start a fight I want to
say it's like Wolverine somebody does
something and like this pops off and
like they all start fighting on asteroid
and magneto is like you know what I've
had enough I've been taking it easy on
you no more and he's like just to give
you an example knee like snatches up
Wolverine he rips he had a man to him
out of his body and Xavier is like this
is right this is ridiculous this is
enough Xavier shuts down the mind of
magneto right he's just like done like
literally shuts his mind down and puts
magneto in a catatonic state that's when
you learn for the first time in Marvel
Comics that Wolverine actually has bone
claws and that is that is they're not
adamantium they weren't put in and they
were always there they were just
adamantium coated so as a result of
shutting down the mind of magneto what
we didn't know what we found out later
was that Magneto's consciousness entered
the mind of Xavier and Magneto like
hates humanity right he's just like man
I hate humanity so much because like all
they do is post stupid stuff on Twitter
and so he was really really really
pissed off and that anger went into the
mind of Xavier
well Xavier at the same time was getting
frustrated with humanity because they
just wouldn't coexist with mutants and
this all comes to a head when you end up
having like some mutant kid who shot and
killed basically on the doorsteps of
these
your Institute and so Xavier is like all
right and when he finally reaches this
tipping point well then like the hatred
of humanity that magneto had merges with
Xavier frustration of humanity and it
creates onslaught but it doesn't
actually manifest itself it's just kind
of like a personality in Xavier head and
so like all these weird things start
going on right like all these weird
things start happening eventually like
onslaught the onslaught entity picks up
on x-men Nate grey right let those guys
I don't know who x-man is there was a
story called Age of Apocalypse basically
the son of Charles Xavier Legion who you
guys should know from the FX series
which is amazing Legion had this idea
that he could basically make Xavier life
easier if he went to the Past and killed
Megan magneto before he became Agni doe
the result is that Xavier jumps in the
way and Xavier dies when this happens a
villain called apocalypse seizes control
of North America and then almost all of
the world and so that leads into the Age
of Apocalypse storyline where you
basically get an alternate reality where
the x-men we're never formed by Xavier
they were formed by magneto but what
ended up happening is the villain mr.
sinister had come to the conclusion that
if Cyclops and Jean Grey were to ever
have a kid it would be crazy powerful
and so what he did is he took their
genetic material and he created an
offspring called Nate grey and Nate grey
was just crazy powerful and so
eventually the Adriel talked lips comes
to an end and Nate gray escapes the Age
of Apocalypse universe by like sheer
force of will leaves the universe and
shows up in the main Marvel Universe
anyway so Nate gray the best way to
think about him is he's everything cable
could have been had cable not been
infected with a techno-organic virus but
when onslaught picks up on Nate gray
like he kind of like telepathically
reaches out to him and then make grace
snatches the onslaught personality away
from Xavier 's body and then like gives
it a physical form not realizing what
he's done and so following that like
onslaught and Xavier are two different
people but then like onslaught starts
masquerading as Xavier and then like
tries to turn the x-men in like a
weaponize team he's like okay guys you
know how like we always had the peaceful
coexistence thing and the x-men are like
yeah and he's like okay so we're not
doing that anymore we're gonna have some
cookies and milk and then we're gonna
kill everyone and the x-men are just
like but wait a minute though like
that's not what we're supposed to do in
Xavier is like and I would have gotten
away with it too if it was a few
meddling kids or onslaught was like that
you know and so like onslaught basically
takes off like he leaves but like along
the way he's doing like all these crazy
things so it's like like before that
happened I before that point went
onslaught you know like appears to the
x-men it's crazy because like he attacks
the juggernaut and like punches him like
a cross across the country or across the
world I can't which one and then like he
like
crash lands in New York and so like
beast and Bishop come across him and
they're like what the hell's going on
and and and like juggernauts like dude
on slots coming and they're like who the
hell's on slugs like he's like he was
gonna kill us all and so fast forward
that's when like onslaught meets the
x-men and like you know crazy things
start popping off and then honestly it
just starts being a dick like he goes to
Jean Grey he's like hey I have a secret
and she's like what's that he's like
Xavier has always been in love with you
and she's like all Mark it's just stuff
like that just being an [ __ ] but
nonetheless
so eventually onslaught picks up on on
Franklin Richards the son of Reed
Richards and Susan storm the
reality-warping kid and he's like this
kid has a lot of power but he also has
like psychic blocks that his father put
in place so that he could be protected
against people like me that's the reason
why xavier can't just like dominate the
mind of franklin richards and seize
control of him because Reed Richards put
all these mental blocks in place so one
control Franklin's powers and to make
sure that he couldn't be manipulated by
like a telepath or something like that
and so on slots like okay the kid has to
let me in willingly and so what he does
is he creates like this little this
little kid persona and like starts
spending time with Franklin Richards
like becoming his best friend and so
eventually like he enters into the
subconscious mind of Franklin and then
absorbs him and so like now he's got
like Franklin Richards reality-warping
powers and then he goes after x-man Nate
grey because he couldn't take out x-man
by himself so he goes out your x-man
make grey with the power Franklin
Richards and it's just like you're mine
now and then absorbs Nate grey and so
then it's just like okay so this guy is
basically God now and then he goes on
like invades a sentinel base takes his
sentinels and then makes like this giant
barrier around like Central Park in New
York or something like that so you have
like Spider Man and the Green Goblin who
were basically fighting against these
sentinels you've got the Fantastic Four
you got the Avengers and you got the
x-men are just like what do we do like
everybody's panicking right it's like we
have no idea so then like the Watchers
watching everything unfold and then you
realize apocalypse is there and this is
a goal son dude apocalypse man so I was
like okay so apocalypse is there an
apocalypse shows up to the x-men with
like cable ie shows the x-men the
Fantastic Four in the Avengers and he's
like I have a plan and they're like
you're a bad guy though and he's like
yes but you can trust me because like
you know I want to live too and so so
they're like okay so he's like we're
gonna go into the mind of Xavier and of
onslaught and we're gonna like take back
Franklin Richards and we're gonna take
back Nate grey and then we're gonna like
we're gonna save everybody and so like
they they have like this preemptive
strike that takes out Xavier and then
like onslaught basically becomes like a
pure form of energy and so then like
apocalypse and cable to go inside and
try to take out Franklin Richards and
Nate gray and then apocalypse is just
like halt I had an actual master plan
the hold
like it was like what was your master
plan is like to kidnap Franklin Richards
and to make him into my new host so I
can become God and they're like Susan
storm appears out of nowhere right like
she followed them in she was invisible
the whole time it leads to them failing
and so because the fact that they fail
you know oh man because of the fact that
they failed Jean Grey comes along and
says okay so basically onslaught is like
this insanely impenetrable armor that
houses like perfect psychic energy and
so like we can't defeat it like we're
not strong enough to defeat him but I
know someone who is and they're like who
and it's like The Incredible Hulk and
they're like yeah but like he's not he's
not strong though and they're like and
that's that's what he end up finding out
like woman oh no what banners been doing
all this time is like reeling the Hulk
in so we're gonna stop that so Jean Grae
suppresses the mind of Bruce Banner
inside the Incredible Hulk The
Incredible Hulk reverts to like a
mindless beast so just like unfathomable
rage and then just like runs up on
onslaught and just like rips him up
heart right just like tears into his
armor and everything and reveals the
psychic energy like rip sea armor to
pieces and so like all this left is this
Inca poriyal energy and so Thor is just
like everybody dive in so like they all
just go jumping in right everybody
except for the x-men because the expert
are selling and there's no need to
reboot them so so like the Avengers the
Fantastic Four the let's see like um
Doctor Doom like a couple other people
they all jump into the to the psychic
energy of onslaught and then on sauce
basically defeated when like naita Nate
grey and and Franklin Richards are
rescued and then everything returns to
normal and so like all the heroes who
jumped in the onslaught they're reborn
in the heroes reborn universe which
turned out to be a universe that
Franklin Richards made you know just
because he wanted them to be to be alive
again so he walks around like this blue
ball and then eventually he has to make
the choice and so he reckons America
resurrects them all um he brings them
all from from the heroes reborn universe
back to the main Marvel Universe and
then destroys the heroes reborn universe
so so that's that's the original
onslaught right and then you get you get
everything after that now here's the
deal onslaught could not actually show
up in the MCU until you got the x-men
movies but even if he did it wouldn't
matter now here's the thing man like but
it took a mindless Incredible Hulk to
give them the opening they needed to win
if Jean Grey hadn't suppressed the
banner persona and like the incredible
whole version like just ran upon on foot
and beat the tar out of it and tore its
armor open they all would have died cuz
like onslaught 1 it's like merged all of
humanity into like a single
consciousness because hell if I know why
and then like wanted to like like spread
his influence out into the universe
which he could have done with Franklin
Richards powers and in a crazed powers
like he want to do all these weird and
bonkers things that would have happened
if it hadn't been for Jean Grey
suppressing the incredible whole so one
like the Axman has to be in the universe
for this to happen just because you have
to be able to have a
and Magneto to be able to pull it off
but even then if you're talking about
like a fully powered onslaught going off
against all the superheroes in the main
model you never in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe they would all get crushed like
they would all be decimated because like
they're just too weak now here's the
thing here's the thing that they could
do get the Infinity Gauntlet because
like I mean all some would be like just
like decimated by the Infinity goal I
mean it's the Infinity Gauntlet man you
could use the Infinity Gauntlet or
something like that but there are other
caveats like they can have characters
like Matthew Malloy you can have the
molecule man Owen Reese certainly the
Beyonder could do it there's a lot of
characters out there that could pull
that off I mean there's a lot of things
to you there's a lot of hair as they
could use to defeat him but like the MCU
as it stands now not a chance it takes a
man be absolute pandemonium like it'd be
it'd be bonkers they wouldn't stand a
chance it'd be a bloodbath man it'd be
like a Tony Stark so what's going on
well you know Rogers is on slots here
and so now we're all gonna die and it's
like well it's been good knowing he had
Tony even though you were kind of a dick
like none of them would live they would
all day tall and I'm getting killed it'd
be awesome like it'd be awesome to see I
mean it wouldn't be also seeing you
killed I mean what kind of I mean let's
be honest guys how many of us want to
see a Marvel Cinematic Universe movie
where like everyone dies like that's
what I want to see I want to see it go
down it's morbid
it's Mormon and it's messed up but like
it'd be kind of cool to see but no
orange slot would be yeah it would it
would I mean they wouldn't stand a
chance just pure wrath and psychic
energy is all it would be and it would
just it would be an absolute massacre I
mean he would he would sweep through the
Marvel Cinematic Universe like a plague
but still like I mean I think I'm a kind
of interesting movie seems like things
like that I think should be things where
it's like hey like here's what happened
it's like a what-if story well like it
doesn't actually happen in the main
Marvel Cinematic Universe and they
couldnt really do it it's too soon for
that
but here's alright yeah here's the thing
guys you're something important to
remember as cool as it would be to see
onslaught like run amuck and the Marvel
Cinematic Universe there's still ways to
defeat him it would be a whole different
beast if it was like the marquee of
death like dad to see that right there
there's no way they could stop him like
the marquee of death would just wave his
hand and wipe out the universe and that
would be the end of that and it would
just dim it would be five seconds long
right like Hyde Winship shows up and
it's just like Oh Sun is quiet lunch mmm
they were like this and then as the
second was gonna happen man like it's
very they're gonna be like oh man man
Sunderbans hardships here is like yes
man collide when Jim is here and you
guys try to defeat him they eat him beat
him he just pissed him off and now you
cuz now he's gonna wipe out the whole
universe y'all is you baby I was so
screwed I don't even know how screwed
York it would be something funny to see
but anyway guys if you are new here to
comments explain make sure you guys have
the sub button to become part of the Rob
core if you guys enjoyed this video
make sure you drop it like I liked
making these things right it's kind of
ramble on for like like 15 minutes about
why character so damn powerful and they
wouldn't work in the most amount
universe the most fun video I have going
right now and I will catch you all later
peace
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]